[موسيقى]
مافيا متشعبه تتربص ثمان دول جذورها في
اوروبا وتحاول قطعها عبر تنفيذ حمله
مداهمات واعتقالات واسعه ندرين جيتا
مجموعه ايطاليه اجراميه وقع معظم اعضائها
في قبضه الشرطه الاوروبيه من خلال عمليه
امنيه واسعه النطاق
في المانيا اتخذت الشرطه في العديد من
الولايات الفيدراليه اجراءات ضد اعضاء
المافيا عبر تنفيذ عدد من اوامر القبض
بمشاركه اكثر من الف ضابط اما في ايطاليا
اصدرت محكمه اكثر من 100 امر اعتقال بناء
على طلب المدعي العام لمكافحه المافيا
بمشاركه 1400 ضابط شرطه
بلجيكا انضمت ايضا الى الحمله الامنيه حيث
كانت هناك 25 مداهمه للشرطه وتم اعتقال 13
شخصا بينهم سته على الاقل مطلبون بموجب
اوامر اعتقال اوروبيه اصدرتها ايطاليا
هناك ايضا سلطات امنيه اخرى من فرنسا
والبرتغال واسبانيا الى جانب سلوفينيا
ورومانيا نفذوا في الوقت نفسه تدابير ضد
المافيا تنفيذ الاجراء يتم من قبل فريق
تحقيق مشترك يضم اليورو بول الوكاله
المسؤوله عن حفظ الامن في اوروبا
واليوريست المختصه في مجال القضايا
الجنائيه
تعد واحده اقوى منظمات المافيا في العالم
وموطنها الاصلي منطقه كالابريا تنشط منذ
فتره طويله على الصعيد الدولي خارج حدود
ايطاليا تسيطر هذه المجموعه الاجراميه على
تجاره المخدرات الدوليه ولكنها تكسب
اموالها ايضا من تجاره الاسلحه وغسيل
الاموال والفساد
محاولات نزع نواه المافيا في اوروبا بدات
باعتقال السلطات الايطاليه لزعيم المافيا
الايطاليا المطلوب بعد 30 عاما من فداره
من قبضه العداله اياد حمود العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد
مروه البرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات